[Musik]
es war der erste januar 2017 als er kam
um sich mit einem sprung aus dem hilton
hotel das leben zu nehmen
dieses hotel ist eines der größten und
bekanntesten in athen als die gerüchte
über eine amerikanische untersuchung
gegen novartis die runde machten berater
sich in den obersten stock um selbstmord
zu begehen
[Musik]
die leute bei novartis bedauerten die
situation sehr wie konnte ein so
erfolgreicher mann der seine frau und
sein neugeborenes kind in basel
zurückgelassen hatte so etwas tun oder
familie um bambino pina nato
[Musik]
er wollte hier selbstmord begehen
wir treten jetzt in die zweite phase ein
und fangen an uns vorzubereiten wir
werden in kürze zu den zeugen übergehen
zeuge oder zeuge sie ist jetzt bereit
monika
macht ja bringen sie mir nein bringen
sie mit den zeugen c
soll ich ihn komplett verhüllen ja
seinen ganzen körper begleiten sie ihnen
bis hierher und lassen sie ihn in den
raum schließen sie die tür während sie
ihn vorbereiten ok
herzlich willkommen bitte machen sie es
sich bequem
wir müssen uns gut vorbereiten denn wir
werden in den nächsten tag nach amerika
reisen um dort aus zu sagen und unsere
beweise gegen novartis vorzulegen
was sie tun ist sehr großzügig nicht
jeder ist mutig genug sie haben mut
qualitäten die hat mister hamas wir
haben sie gebeten eine maske zu tragen
denn wenn ihnen etwas zustoßen würde
wäre die ganze ermittlung gefährdet
wir tragen eine große verantwortung es
ist wieder kampf zwischen david und
goliath
wir können nie wieder zulassen dass ein
multinationales unternehmen nach
griechenland kommt und illegal und
unethisch handelt
hinter der maske verbirgt sich einer der
drei hauptzeugen die mit den anwälten
dieser berühmten athener kanzlei
zusammenarbeiten um den schweizer
pharmariese novartis wegen korruption
anzuklagen die zeugen sind vom fbi
geschützte informanten
sie bekommt haben code namen erhalten a
b und c sie sind drei ehemalige manager
der griechischen niederlassung sie
wissen nicht wer die anderen zeugen sind
keiner darf wissen wer sie sind nicht
einmal wir
es sind nur noch wenige tage bis zu
ihrer ausreise in die usa und wir werden
sie in dieser heiklen phase der beweis
vorbereitung begleiten heute bereiten
sie sich unter druck ihre anwälte auf
die verhöre durch das fbi vor
ich bin arzt privates stellt gute
medikamente her ich verschreibe das
medikament weil ich glaube dass es gut
ist
können sie beweisen dass ich meinen
patienten das medikament nicht nur
verschrieben habe weil es gutes sondern
auch um im gegenzug geld von novartis zu
erhalten die soldatin war dies
ich kann beweisen dass der arzt dafür
bezahlt wurde ein medikament zu
verschreiben und dass er sich überhaupt
nicht für die gesundheit seiner
patienten interessierte
das hier ist ein internes dokument in
dem die firma den verkäufern erklärt was
sie den ärzten sagen sollen um ihr ziel
zu erreichen
[Musik]
nämlich die verschreibung von novartis
medikamenten
und ist das ein verbrechen ich bin ein
unternehmer ich bin ein geschäftsmann
und ich will meinen umsatz steigern und
das ist illegal wenn man illegale
methoden anwendet ist das natürlich ein
verbrechen facebook mit der wichtige gar
das musst du mir erklären die illegalen
methoden die musst du mir beweisen also
wann hätte er diese 1200 euro erhalten
hätten sie sie ihn vor oder nach der
ausstellung der rezepte gegeben sie
hätten ihm die 1200 euro nach einer
gründlichen prüfung und nur dann gegeben
wenn er die erforderlichen rezepte
ausgestellt hätte
in einem monat
wir haben uns entschlossen eine so große
klage einzureichen weil wir sowohl
anwälte als auch bürger sind
wenn ein anwalt erkennt dass er zum
kampf gegen korruption beitragen kann
muss er die herausforderung annehmen
denn es handelt sich um ein verbrechen
das nicht nur die griechische
gesellschaft betrifft sondern das
gesundheitswesen auf globaler ebene
haben sie verstanden warum das so
wichtig ist
wenn sie es mir nicht sagen werden sie
es auch den amerikanischen nichts sagen
ist das klar
sie müssen sagen dass wir uns die
verschreibung tabellen ansehen und bevor
wir ihm das geld geben schauen wir ob er
das ziel von 50 neuen patienten erreicht
habt 50 neue patienten verflucht das ist
es was ich von ihnen hören möchte
ich wollte es gerade sagen
sprich deutlich nicht durch die zähne
aus kultur hören sie ich verstehe dass
sie gestresst sind das sind dinge die
sie wissen und von denen sie glauben
dass andere sie wissen lassen sie uns
weitermachen
[Musik]
diese untersuchung begann ende 2016 mit
dem justizministerium und dem fbi und
wir haben seitdem mehr als 50.000
dokumente übergeben
[Musik]
in den nächsten tagen werden die
whistleblower vor den amerikanischen
behörden aussagen sie werden jeweils
allein auftreten denn die whistleblower
wissen nicht wer die anderen sind
[Musik]
warum die amerikanische justiz
involviert ist wir sind in new york und
die wall street ist das herzstück der
weltwirtschaft die börse ist ja
angesiedelt und das multinationale
unternehmen novartis ist ihr notiert
sobald ein unternehmen an der börse
notiert ist haben die amerikanischen
behörden automatisch das recht
nachforschungen anzustellen
werden straftaten aufgedeckt können sie
das unternehmen mit einer geldstrafe
belegen
[Musik]
apa
laut amerikanischen die amerikanischen
behörden akzeptieren nicht einfach jeden
beweis wir legen unsere erkenntnisse vor
und sie müssen alle informationen gegen
prüfen und verifizieren wir arbeiten mit
einem amerikanischen anwalt zusammen um
ein besseres verständnis für das
rechtssystem zu entwickeln
[Musik]
in christo moment wir bereiten uns
gerade auf ein treffen mit vertretern
des us
justizministeriums des fvs ii der
securities exchange commission for wir
bereiten den informanten darauf vor den
inhalt der dokumente zu erklären um die
wahrheit zu beweisen
dokumentationen wir verfügen über eine
vielzahl von unterlagen die beweise die
wir gesammelt haben sind umfangreich das
ist ein historischer fall denn die
informanten sind leute die für novartis
gearbeitet haben
sie haben uns genügend beweise dafür
geliefert dass der konzern in kriminelle
aktivitäten verwickelt ist wie das ganze
land betreffen
dieser whistleblower ist im namen der
nation ein risiko eingegangen und das
ist eine schande ein informant sollte
eine art held sein aber er muss sich in
hotels in amerika verstecken
[Musik]
hier haben wir die aufzeichnung der
buchhaltungs nachweis eine beschreibung
wie wir die ärzte bestochen haben
[Musik]
wir haben uns auf diesen arzt
konzentriert
die tabellen zeigen wie viel geld wir
verdienen
und was wir dafür vom arzt verlangen
was ich morgen den behörden vorlägen
werde ist das ergebnis eines registers
dass sich selbst erstellt habe
wichtig ist wie detailliert diese
informationen sind
sie müssen die im justizministerium den
inhalt all dieser seiten erklären und
sicherstellen dass sie ihn verstehen
seite für seite
[Musik]
es ist spät in der nacht
die anwälte und whistleblower bereiten
sich auf den entscheidenden kampf gegen
den pharmariesen ford mit sitz im
schweizerischen basel
[Musik]
vom filialen mit niederlassungen in mehr
als 100 ländern weltweit und 130.000
mitarbeitern erwirtschaftete novartis im
vergangenen jahr die astronomische summe
von 52 milliarden dollar
für schuldig befunden wird oder einem
vergleich zustimmt werden die
informanten nach us recht mehrere
millionen dollar erhalten
[Musik]
glauben sie mir niemand macht so etwas
wegen des geldes
bei mir oder schädigt us aus ethischen
gründen
wenn die leute das wegen des geldes
machen würden warum gibt es dann nicht
tausende von leuten wie mich
[Musik]
es begann alles im jahr 2006 im jahr
2006 war novartis noch nicht die nummer
eins in griechenland aber unser ziel war
es die nummer eins zu werden und so
mussten wir die ärzte dazu bringen so
viele medikamente wie möglich zu
verschreiben das war unser einziges ziel
ist den ostring objektiver
ich war für eine reihe von großen und
kleinen verkaufsteams verantwortlich
[Musik]
ich hatte verschiedene verkäufer die
unter mir arbeiteten von 10 bis 20
haben sie persönlich vertreter dazu
gezwungen gegen geld falsche dokumente
auszustellen
das war meine aufgabe
ich bat meine kollegen erst zu tun und
ich erhielt die anweisungen von meinen
vorgesetzten
disposition dann gaben sie mir das geld
das auf die verschiedenen programme zur
bestechung der ärzte aufgeteilt wurde
[Musik]
ich musste dafür sorgen dass alle
verkäufer und das marketing team das
geld an die ärzte verteilten damit wir
davon profitieren konnten
die
[Musik]
datenbank enthält tausende von ärzten
über 30.000 ärzte aufgeteilt nach
verschiedenen kriterien
garten eine akte über jeden arzt mit den
details über die vereinbarung darüber
wie viele schreiben musste um das geld
zu erhalten
[Musik]
wie soll die kita war motto city mal wir
haben sie jede woche kontaktiert um sie
an ihr verkaufsziel zu erinnern
und sie traten aber die farbe aber es
ging um medikamente nicht um süßigkeiten
also begannen wir uns zu fragen oder
zumindest fragte ich mich was zum teufel
wir hier tun
die annäherung war nicht einfach er war
derjenige der uns den weg geebnet hat
er war sehr gestresst ich sagte ihm sei
nicht rauche ich heute könnte der beste
tag deines lebens sein
du musst nur einen anderen weg
einschlagen als den den du bisher
gegangen bist
bisher haben sie eine karriere als
krimineller gemacht jetzt können sie bei
unseren ermittlungen helfen damit der
gerechtigkeit genüge getan wird und er
akzeptierte damit fing alles an und nach
einer weile kam der zweite novartis
manager zu uns gefolgt vom 3 novartis
manager
gar nicht die produktion innovativer
nowacki motto eines der von novartis
eingesetzten bestechungs programme hieß
exakt das war sehr wichtig denn dank
exactly wurde novartis im jahr 2010 die
nummer eins es war das größte programm
und es wurde für drei produkte zur
behandlung von bluthochdruck eingesetzt
es waren die ova exforge und rasilez
brasil ist
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier von über zweieinhalb
millionen euro die den ärzten für die
verschreibung dieser drei medikamente
gezahlt wurden
wollen sie damit sagen dass über dieses
programm zweieinhalb millionen euro an
bestechungsgeldern an ärzte gezahlt
wurden sie ja innerhalb von acht monaten
warnte medizin wie vielen ärzten
etwa 1000 ärzte
[Musik]
nicht alle ärzte bekamen den gleichen
betrag je mehr rezepte sie ausstellten
dass du mir gleich bekamen sie
manche ärzte bekamen 5000 oder 6000 euro
andere nur 1000
aber sie müssen wissen dass gleichzeitig
auch andere programme liefen nicht nur
exakt
konnte so 5000 euro über exactly und
dann weitere 3000 euro für dasselbe
medikament über ein anderes programm
bekommen und so konnte er sogar bis zu
15.000 euro für die drei medikamente
bekommen
bewahrte es hatte jedes jahr über 50
bestechungs programme
[Musik]
und woher kam das geld
kam direkt aus basel
der griechische direktor und die
topmanager fuhren nach basel und das
budget wurde dort festgelegt sie
stabilisierten fest wie viel geld jedes
jahr in griechenland benötigt wurde
alles war durchgeplant von der höhe des
geldes bis zum zeitpunkt der auszahlung
[Musik]
novartis hatte ein ziel einen
sogenannten return on investment
für jede zweieinhalb oder drei millionen
die ausgegeben wurden erhielt das
unternehmen etwa zehn zurück
[Musik]
woher kennen sie diese zahlen
die waren in der firma allgemein bekannt
die leute wussten sie
wussten sie also dass sie zweieinhalb
millionen für schmiergelder hatten sie
geben und zwar einhalb millionen und
müssen zehn millionen zurück bekommen
das fbi hat diese zahlen alles was ich
ihnen gesagt habe habe ich auch dem fbi
gesagt
[Musik]
hat novartis all diese millionen euro an
bestechungsgeldern verbucht
[Musik]
nach aussagen des zeugen wurden diese
beträge als zahlungen für ärzte
hinterlegt die einen klinischen studien
über die möglichen nebenwirkungen der
medikamente teilnahmen indem sie
bestimmte fragebogen ausfüllten
[Musik]
wenn irgendwelche staatlichen kontrollen
durchgeführt worden wären hätte alles
einwandfrei ausgesehen
[Musik]
in wirklichkeit handelte es sich jedoch
um bestechungsgelder denn diese studien
waren für die ärzte bestimmt aber die
meisten fragebögen wurden von den pharma
verkäufern selbst ausgefüllt
diese studien waren gefälscht es waren
keine wirklichen studien sie wurden
nicht von den ärzten durchgeführt und
dient nicht der arzneimittelsicherheit
wurde also das leben von menschen aufs
spiel gesetzt nur um den umsatz zu
steigern
das kann ich nicht sagen aber ich weiß
mit sicherheit von medikamenten
sicherlich nicht gut für die menschen
ist
[Musik]
die ärzte mussten über verschreiben um
ihr ziel zu erreichen
wie muss ich mir als außenstehender
diese situation vorstellen
ein verkäufer geht zum arzt der 1000
patienten hat und plötzlich verschreibt
der arzt das medikament an 600 leute
ist es so passiert
[Musik]
natürlich die ärzte hatten die rezept
locker die sie vom staat bekommen haben
die verkäufer überprüften die
verschreibungen jede woche manchmal
sogar zweimal pro woche
das sieht sie wollten sicherstellen dass
alles wie geplant ablief
in vielen fällen riefen sie sogar die
patienten an um die verschreibungen zu
überprüfen
nein das ist nicht legal es ist illegal
diese checks waren teil der vereinbarung
von vereinbarungen lautete sie erhalten
diese gefälschte klinische studie aber
ich der verkäufer werde ich jede woche
vielleicht sogar jeden tag während ihrer
studie vorbeikommen um jeder
verschreibungen zu überprüfen
[Musik]
und ich werde mich vergewissern dass
dieses rezept echt ist
wenn es echt ist werden wir sie bezahlen
wenn nicht bezahlen wir sie nicht
was ist mit all diesen dokumenten
passiert
die anweisung lautete alles zu löschen
was sie auf ihrem computer hatten sie
kamen zu unseren sagten okay macht euren
computer an und löschte alle dateien die
er über die ärzte hab die zahlungen die
programme
das waren die sogenannten säuberung star
auf dem jahr hat man sie aufgefordert
die daten zu löschen
ein oder zweimal im jahr kommen sie zu
uns allen vom assistenten bis zum chef
und baten uns alles zu löschen
[Musik]
von der erstellung der programme bis zur
vernichtung der beweise war alles bis
ins kleinste detail geplant um die
zahlung von bestechungsgeldern in
millionenhöhe zu ermöglichen nach
angaben der ft whistleblower zog einer
der verfechter dieser pläne später nach
amerika in den hier von new york
wir haben uns auf die suche nach ihm
gemacht
architekten dieser gefälschten
klinischen studien war starr großen der
kosovare die treibende kraft hinter
diesen programmen
er machte karriere bei novartis war eine
vertrauensperson im management team und
ging nach seiner erfahrung in basel als
direktor in die vereinigten staaten
[Musik]
er verwaltete das geld indem er es den
verschiedenen bestechungs programmen
zuordnete und die bestechungsgelder
verwaltete zum beispiel wie viel geld
genau und wie viel in andere programme
floss er ist eine schlüsselfigur die
sehr viel weiß
[Musik]
lasst uns fahren er ist wütend
er hat die tür geöffnet und ich fragte
ihn ob er der star wissen jacobs ist der
in die fbi ermittlungen verwickelt ist
[Musik]
seine frau war wie versteinert
es ist klar dass er von dieser
untersuchung wusste
ich sagte zu ihm hören sie ich bin
gekommen weil sie das recht haben zu
sagen was sie wollen was sie denken denn
die anschuldigungen gegen sie sind sehr
ernst
und er sagte gehen sie weg gehen sie weg
ich habe nichts zu sagen
[Musik]
ich wollte keine aufsehen erregen weil
da zwei kinder waren und so bin ich
natürlich gegangen
er bat mich sofort zu gehen und ich
sagte okay ich gehe
[Musik]
heute hat whistleblower b seine beweise
den amerikanischen behörden übergeben
ssid gfk
wir haben mindestens neun stunden lang
daran gearbeitet aber wir sind zufrieden
wir haben alles erklärt
wir haben die pflicht beweise zu liefern
wir reden nur wenn wir beweise haben
wenn wir keine beweise haben reden wir
nicht
diese dokumente enthüllen das gesamte
system zur bestechung der ärzte
solche verschreibungen im austausch für
bestimmte vorteile hatten enorme
auswirkungen auf das griechische
gesundheitssystem
[Musik]
die finanzkrise hat griechenland 2008
schwer getroffen tausende von menschen
verloren ihren arbeitsplatz und damit
auch ihr recht auf gesundheitsversorgung
bitte setzen sie sich
[Musik]
medikamente die von den patienten
bezahlt werden werden der matura viele
menschen können sich eine behandlung
nicht mehr leisten das andere können sie
in der apotheke bekommen dort kostet es
nicht viel nur einen euro ich habe ein
anderes für sieben euro
private initiativen haben zur gründung
von gemeinnützigen kliniken und
apotheken geführt wie diese im zentrum
athens wo in diesem zeitraum mehr als
35.000 menschen eine kostenlose
medizinische versorgung erhalten haben
kann ich dieses anstelle des andere
nehmen es hat die gleiche wirkung
richtig
und doch contento wahrte seinen umsatz
während der finanzkrise fast verdoppeln
den berg erklimmen und die nummer eins
in griechischen pharmasektor werden
konstantinos fluss leitete die
griechische niederlassung zu dieser zeit
es geht uns gut
radio weitestgehend und es ist sicher
nicht notwendig diese informationen zu
verbreiten weil wir sonst zur
zielscheibe werden
wissen sie da draußen können sie es kaum
erwarten geld von denen zu holen denen
es gut geht deshalb freuen wir uns
lieber nach innen und zeigen es nicht
nach außen
[Musik]
heute ist whistleblower c an der reihe
vor den amerikanischen behörden aus zu
sagen dass es der zeuge der unter
anderem eine reihe von audiodaten
vorgelegt hat in denen wir gespräche
unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit in
der führungsetage hören können
sie sprechen darüber wie sie wirklich
denken und geben ihre wahren ziele preis
sie habe ich bleiben
wir sind die ersten die erfahren was im
ministerium passieren wird die
beteiligten selbst informieren uns bevor
sie entscheidungen treffen
sie informieren uns auch über ihre
nächsten schritte damit für sie im
voraus beeinflussen können
[Musik]
war basel darüber informiert was in
griechenland geschah
das natürlich basel war der hauptsitz
des unternehmens von basel aus kamen die
anweisungen wie das ganze
korruptionssystem abzulaufen hatte
diese anweisungen wurden immer befolgt
[Musik]
die manager aus basel kamen oft zu
besprechungen
[Musik]
waren sie bei den treffen mit den
vertretern aus der schweiz anwesend
sie kamen um zu sehen wie wir das
korruptions programm gestartet haben
ja noch simple der es handelte sich
immer um illegale projekte die als
legitime projekte getarnt waren in
wirklichkeit dienten sie dazu
korruptionsgelder zu verstecken
sie waren dabei sehr vorsichtig weil sie
angst vor einer untersuchung hatten wie
wir sie jetzt haben
[Musik]
klassiker war medici die mediziner
wurden von uns klassifiziert die
buchstaben a b und c kennzeichneten die
fähigkeiten der mediziner je nach ihrer
position und ihrer fähigkeit rezepte
auszustellen
universitätsprofessoren und klinikleiter
wurden immer unter eingestuft unter b
waren diejenigen die eine mäßige anzahl
von rezepten ausstellen konnten unter c
diejenigen die wenig verschrieben
[Musik]
unser hauptziel war es so viele ärzte
wie möglich in der kategorie a zu haben
erster klasse diese klassifizierung
wurde also verwendet um zu beurteilen
wie viel geld sie ihnen zahlen konnten
die mediziner wussten nichts von dieser
klassifizierung niemand von novartis
würde jemals zu einem professor gehen
und ihm sagen sie sind als a 1 a 2 oder
3 eingestuft worden
die magic ii sg hausen der ärzte wurden
registriert und bestochen aber es gab
noch mehr den fbi whistleblowern zufolge
gingen diese korruption weit über
griechenland hinaus um bestimmte
projekte zu ermöglichen
[Musik]
es gab ein projekt bei novartis das euro
dollar hieß es war ein weltweites
projekt es ging um zwei medikamente
lucentis und avastin beide produkte sind
praktisch identisch basieren auf
demselben molekül und wirken auf
dieselbe weise bei der behandlung von
makula partie und andere
netzhauterkrankungen
[Musik]
gutsche lisa avastin roche vermarktet
avastin lucentis hingegen wurde von
novartis vermarktet der einzige
unterschied zwischen den beiden
medikamenten ist ihr preis eine dosis
avastin kostet zwischen 30 und 50 dollar
während eine dosis lucentis über 1000
dollar kostet
die produktion von avastin einzustellen
weil es sich negativ auf die einnahmen
von lucentis auswirkte
und was für anweisungen haben sie
bekommen was sollten sie tun
dafür sorgen dass avastin nicht weltweit
verbreitet wird und die versicherung
dazu bringen die kosten dafür nicht mehr
zu erstatten
was die mediziner betrifft so lautete
der auftrag sie einzuschüchtern
wir sollten sie einschüchtern wenn sie
avastin verwenden wollten
wir sprechen von der regierung von
regierungsangestellten von medizinischem
personal und
[Musik]
das also war der auftrag der in basel
erteilt wurde die verwendung des
konkurrierenden medikaments auf globaler
ebene zu verhindern ärzte in angst und
schrecken zu versetzen indem man sie
glauben ließ avastin sei gefährlich und
die gesundheitspolitik der regierungen
zu beeinflussen
er wurde quasi quotidiano es ist unser
täglich brot einerseits üben wir druck
auf die verschiedenen minister aus
andererseits arbeiten wir mit ihnen
zusammen damit sie uns nicht nur für
einfache apotheker halten
was ich damit sagen will ist dass es im
moment zwei böse buben gibt die
apotheker und roche
[Musik]
das ist ein geschäftsbericht von herrn
voß aus dem jahr 2011 in dem heer france
seinen vorgesetzten erzählt was
passieren wird wenn avastin zugelassen
wird
gewinner ist politik am ende er erklärt
dass der umsatz von lucentis von märz
bis dezember um bis zu 25 prozent
zurückgehen könnte
3,8 millionen dollar in zehn monaten
und was haben sie empfohlen
argumentation die schaffung einer
speziellen abteilung um gegen die
verwendung von avastin zu argumentieren
mit den interessensgruppen zu
kommunizieren um eine strategie mit dem
gesundheitsministerium und dem
sozialversicherungsfonds zu entwickeln
um das risiko der verwendung von avastin
zu verringern
erklären sie mir noch einmal was genau
sollten sie tun
das war eine anleitung zur durchführung
des ganzen korruptions programms alles
was man tun musste war diese drei
schritte zu befolgen um die verwendung
von avastin zu verhindern
wir haben es den ärzten klargemacht hier
ist ihr geld hören sie auf avastin zu
verwenden wir reden hier von wirklich
viel geld wir haben es an die gesamte
augenheilkunde gemeinschaft bezahlt
damit sie avastin nicht mehr verwendet
die fusion
wie viel haben sie ihnen gezahlt
es waren über zwei millionen pro jahr
sie haben mich gefragt wie viel geld sie
genommen haben meine antwort lautet sehr
viel aber denken sie daran dass es nur
einen euro braucht um von korruption zu
sprechen und das ist eine situation zu
der es gar nicht erst kommen sollte
[Musik]
stellen sie sich mal vor sie gehen zum
arzt und er verschreibt ihnen ein
medikament das überhaupt nicht brauchen
sie haben also ärzte dazu ermutigt
lucentis zu verschreiben
ja durchaus auch so was gab's
patienten wurden aus verschiedensten
gründen ins krankenhaus eingeliefert und
die ärzte verschrieben ihnen lucentis
auch wenn es für ihre behandlung gar
nicht erforderlich war
das war schockierend deshalb bin ich
jetzt hier ich konnte es nicht mehr
ertragen
[Musik]
wir hatten einen über 16 stündiges
treffen mit der mittleren aus den
vereinigten staaten
stellen sie sich einen großen
konferenztisch vor
auf der einen seite vertreter des fbi
der ssi und des justizministeriums zwei
staatsanwälte und ein übersetzer
auf den tisch die gesamte dokumentation
auf der anderen seite ein zeuge die
spannung steigt
ich kann ihnen nicht so viel verraten
aber sehen sie sich dieses bild an
es wirkt makellos
sehen sie wie würden sie es verstehen
niemand hier verteilt geld geht nissan
von mai und wog schliesslich würde
niemand ein dokument erstellen in dem
steht so stellen wir fallen mit bildern
von menschen die anderen geld zahlen
pagano mal drei personen
schauen sie bitte hier
das sind nur nette menschen wie können
wir ohne einen informanten verstehen was
dort wirklich vor sich geht
trotz des stresses den sie haben trotz
allem was sie durchmachen sind die
informanten die leute an vorderster
front und sie tragen das ganze risiko
[Musik]
ich habe in der zeitung gelesen dass
sich ein mitarbeiter von novartis am
neujahrstag in einem renommierten hotel
in der athener innenstadt aus dem
fenster stürzen wollte
[Musik]
ich kann den druck unter dem er stand
gut verstehen es war eine wirklich
stressige situation
[Musik]
novartis hat ihnen gesagt dass die
situation in der sie sich befanden
völlig normal war von dollar tree sie
attraktiver als die krise in
griechenland aussprach und es den
menschen wirklich schlecht ging fragten
sie sich
inwieweit habe ich ethische standards
verletzt die ich von vornherein nicht
hätte verletzen dürfen
wir aber selbstkritisch genug war
verstand dass man bereits zu weit
gegangen war
[Musik]
wir kamen zu novartis als menschen
menschliche wesen menschliche wesen
zwischen 20 und 50 jahren mit einer
ausgezeichneten ausbildung mit familien
und freunden
und sie haben uns zu kriminellen gemacht
dass es nicht leicht zu ertragen
ich kann mich in szene kiedis
hineinversetzen und verstehen was er
empfunden hat zumindest glaube ich dass
er weiß eine menge er war einer der
architekten dieser systeme in
griechenland er wusste genau wohin das
geld floss und was damit gemacht wurde
und er musste das mit seinem gewissen
vereinbaren
[Musik]
basilea in basel nicht weit vom novartis
hauptsitz entfernt treffen wir nico
szene kindes aber er will mit uns weder
über die behauptungen der whistleblower
noch über die gründe sprechen die ihn
dazu brachten auf die dachterrasse des
hilton zu steigen
[Musik]
er ist ein faktor king roger nach seinem
selbstmordversuch erklärte die
griechische antikorruptionsbehörde im
januar 2017 dass sie bereits vor einiger
zeit eine untersuchung gegen novartis
eingeleitet habe und mit den us behörden
zusammenarbeite
[Musik]
im februar 2018 explodierte der skandal
auf der griechischen politbühne die
griechische staatsanwaltschaft schickte
die akte über die novartis untersuchung
zusammen mit den aussagen der
informanten an das parlament weil sich
unter den namen derjenigen die angeblich
schmiergelder erhalten hatten zehn
minister aus früheren konservativen
regierungen befanden im parlament brach
unweigerlich ein streit aus
[Musik]
ich habe und ich sage es offen volles
vertrauen in die griechische justiz
haben sie irgendetwas gefunden was ihren
hochmut und ansprüche rechtfertigt
hoffnungen träume
so beginnt der albtraum denn der traum
von novartis hat sich in luft aufgelöst
ich habe viele entscheidungen über
medikamente getroffen aber keine die den
menschen geschadet hat
naja wir euch schriftgelehrte und
pharisäer heuchler um jesus christus zu
zitieren solche heuchler wir euch hat es
in der geschichte noch nie gegeben
[Musik]
mein eindruck ist dass es sich um den
größten skandal seit der diktatur in den
1970 er jahren handelt
[Musik]
nach unseren berechnungen hat uns
novartis ab 2005 sechs bis sieben
milliarden euro zu viel berechnet das
war geld das wir niemals hätten zahlen
sollen aber wir haben es getan
dieses problem mit griechenland oder mit
novartis zu tun
es passiert auch in anderen ländern denn
wenn es in anderen ländern nicht
passiert wäre hätten die amerikaner
nicht ermittelt es ist kein griechisches
problem sondern ein weltweites problem
es ist nur so dass wir hier eine
politische klasse haben die bereits gut
war was zum niedergang des landes
beigetragen hat
wir sind novartis wir haben die besten
strategien für unsere marken wir haben
die besten medikamente für unsere
patienten wir haben die besten
hilfsmittel für ärzte um den besten job
zu machen das wissen wir alle und das
sagen wir auch immer wieder erwartet ist
nicht nur der beste arbeitsplatz sondern
auch der beste partner für patienten
ärzte und regierungsmitglieder
wir sind die wichtigste
tochtergesellschaft in ganz europa und
das macht uns einzigartig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die munition der grieche uns wurde
gesagt dass es bei jedem gesetz
grauzonen gibt
das ziel dieses unternehmens war es uns
glauben zu machen dass es sich um
normale geschäftsaktivitäten handelte
[Musik]
wann haben sie gemerkt dass mit dem
unternehmen etwas nicht stimmt
in meinem ersten jahr in diesem job
wurde mir das klar wir dachten uns das
ist ein ziemlich aggressives vorgehen
aber man erkennt nicht einmal die
wirklichen dimensionen dieses
verbrechens
[Musik]
die wette rennen um die nummer eins zu
werden mussten sie nur zwei dinge tun
die ärzte dazu bringen so viel wie
möglich von dem medikament zu
verschreiben und immer höhere preise
festsetzen
einerseits bestachen wartest die ärzte
so viel wie möglich von dem medikament
zu verschreiben und
andererseits erhöhten die
regierungsbeamten die preise ins
unermessliche
[Musik]
griechenland ist eines der länder die
für die festlegung der preise in über 30
ländern verantwortlich sind
es handelte sich also um einen globalen
gewinn
[Musik]
die griechischen arzneimittelpreise
hatten direkte auswirkungen auf die
preise im 30 anderen ländern und wirkten
als multiplikator
in der praxis würde novartis für jeden
zusätzlichen cent der in griechenland
auf den medikamenten preis aufgeschlagen
wird automatisch millionen mehr in der
ganzen welt verdienen
[Musik]
der ministerialrat der damals mit der
berechnung der preise beauftragt war die
sneakers manias
er entwickelte zu diesem zweck eine
komplexe mathematische formel manias
arbeitete jedoch nicht nur für das
ministerium sondern auch als berater für
novartis
[Musik]
money money as hatte über eine
beratungsfirma eine berufliche und
persönliche beziehung zu erwarten
durch diese bekanntschaft waren sie in
der lage die preise aller medikamente in
ganz griechenland zu manipulieren
nach griechischem recht sollen die
preise zu den niedrigsten in europa
gehören aber dank manias formel gehörten
die preise von erwartest du den höchsten
in europa
es war eine sehr komplizierte formeln
niemand wusste wie sich die preise
zusammensetzen
die entscheidungsträger war also ein
[Musik]
wir haben uns dem neuen preis polypen
gestellt wir waren in der lage einen
guten medikamenten preis beizubehalten
was eine gute nachricht für unser
unternehmen ist das gibt uns das geld um
in andere produkte zu investieren
[Musik]
wie haben sie die mitarbeiter von
novartis bezahlt damit sie nicht in
ihren büchern auftauchten
[Musik]
durch beraterverträge die morde diese
ließen alles legitim erscheinen
[Musik]
basilea viele zahlungen wurden direkt in
basel in auftrag gegeben
diese zahlungen wurden als typ b
eingestuft wobei die einfach basel
bedeutet während a für athen steht
das heißt dass basel bei illegalen
projekten intervenierte in dem es geld
direkt aus der schweiz überwies
[Musik]
also das geld kam aus basel
ein teil davon schon
direkt hinter der basilea
waren sie an diesem programm beteiligt
ich kann diese frage nicht beantworten
weil sie meine identität preisgeben
würde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du wartest wurde im jahr 2009 dem
zweiten jahr der griechenland-krise zur
nummer 1
das unternehmen erreichte sein ziel
trotz der krise die in dem land herrscht
du wartest wollte immer mehr und mehr es
hörte nicht auf
sand sie trinken ständig auf mehr umsatz
als bisher wie sie ab und zu bekommen
wir besuch von managern aus basel
die rhetorik motive zucker der ceo kam
immer dorthin wer war das zu dieser zeit
die nummer eins an der spitze der
pyramide
haben sie ihn getroffen als sie nach
griechenland kamen
ja ich habe ihn getroffen was warf ein
mann
[Musik]
er war sehr offen
er war keine typische
führungspersönlichkeit mit viel charisma
erschien ein mensch zu sein dem es
wichtig war das unternehmen schnell
wachsen zu lassen
[Musik]
sein motto war verkaufen verkaufen
verkaufen
[Musik]
minute schickte im jahr 2010 als der
bankrott unausweichlich schien hatte die
griechische regierung keine andere wahl
als die europäischen institutionen um
hilfe zu bitten insbesondere die troika
die aus der europäischen kommission dem
internationalen währungsfonds und der
zentralbank besteht
[Musik]
im gegenzug für ein rettungspaket
verhängte die troika drastische
sparmaßnahmen insbesondere im
gesundheitswesen
nur in griechenland dürften keine neuen
medikamente zugelassen werden der stab
blockierte auch zahlungen an die
pharmaunternehmen
die situation die drei jahre lang
unverändert erwartet häufte kredite in
höhe von 140 millionen euro an und
musste zehn neue produkte zu lassen
[Musik]
um das problem zu lösen wurde 2013
harvard ins leben gerufen dabei handelte
es sich offiziell um ein akademisches
programm zur reform des griechischen
gesundheitssektors
[Musik]
wir nannten es das harvard projekt weil
ein harvard-professor daran beteiligt
war
es war ein projekt das von herrn -
selbst ausging und direkt an novartis in
griechenland gerichtet war
[Musik]
der hauptzweck des harvard projekts
bestand darin der griechischen regierung
eine neue art und weise vorzuschlagen in
der das gesamte gesundheitssystem des
landes funktionieren sollte
[Musik]
es handelte sich um einen akademischen
vorschlag für die regierung die zahl der
medikamente für ihre patienten zu
erhöhen
massing die sind solche aktionen legal
es scheint so dass illegal sind wenn
dieses projekt ein pharmaunternehmen
vorgelegt wurde nicht nur noch warten
ihr eigentlicher aber versteckte zweck
war dass novartis seine medikamente in
griechenland einführen wollte
aber wenn es sich wirklich um ein
akademisches projekt gehandelt hätte
hätten wir einige veröffentlichungen
gefunden und die fehlen alles wurde
hinter verschlossenen türen ausgeheckt
eine sehr wichtige nachricht ist dass
wir etwas erreicht haben worauf wir
gedrängt haben vielleicht sogar schon ab
morgen und das ist ein preis ausschuss
wir haben die voraussetzungen dafür
geschaffen dass er stattfinden kann aus
heutiger sicht ist das etwas das so real
anmutet ich meine ein staat der nicht in
der lage ist seine kosten zu decken mit
geschäften die schließen müssen
entscheidet über die einführung neuer
medikamente
für uns die wir darauf gedrängt haben
ist das eine ausgezeichnete entscheidung
wir wollten dass dieser ausschuss
geschaffen wird
mission
hat novartis bekommen was es wollte
das neue design von novartis thate märz
2013 in kraft ein paar monate später im
august 2013 wurden die neuen
produktpreise veröffentlicht auf die wir
seit drei jahren gewartet hatten
material
außerdem wurden alle zehn neu novartis
produkte zugelassen
wie kurz vor ende des darauffolgenden
jahres wurden alle inländischen schulden
abbezahlt wir sprechen hier von 140
millionen
aber wie ist das möglich die einführung
neuer produkte hat doch gar nicht dazu
beigetragen die schulden zu tilgen
eine sehr gute frage
wenn sie mittel für etwas bereitstellen
wollen müssen sie gleichzeitig andere
mittel aufbringen um diese ausgaben
auszugleichen
das bedeutet dass man in einer anderen
kostenstelle kürzungen vornehmen muss in
diesem fall wurde das medizinische
personal reduziert ich kapital ii machen
[Musik]
die hatten erwartet dass geschafft
und novartis hat einen mann aus dem
militär eingestellt
er wurde von der firma bezahlt damit die
comodo desinteresse
dieser mann war eine vertrauensperson
des gesundheitsministeriums
er war für alle verhandlungen mit der
troika verantwortlich dass anita
[Musik]
er war eine art vermittler zwischen dem
gesundheitsministerium und der troika
was die manipulation des gesamten
sanitäts sektors ermöglichte
[Musik]
us-soldat und professor wollen sie damit
sagen dass novartis einen mann
eingestellt hat der für die kontakte
zwischen der troika und dem gesamten
gesundheitsministerium verantwortlich
war
genauso
es war also nicht die griechische
regierung sondern novartis das mit der
troika zu tun hatte
das ist eine schwerwiegende
anschuldigung und wir warten die
europäische kommission um eine erklärung
wir erhielten jedoch eine lapidare
antwort
wir äußern uns nicht zu laufenden
ermittlungsverfahren
kein wort mehr
[Musik]
nikos manoudakis selbst erklärte sich
jedoch bereit uns an einem schweizer
flughafen zu treffen
wenn ihnen jemand sagt dass ich an dem
harvard projekt beteiligt waren liegt ja
er ist ein lügner ich würde ihn
umbringen und ich werde ihnen noch etwas
über das novartis geld sagen
als ich berater des ministeriums war
habe ich über 200 flüge pro jahr
absolviert 200 flüge im jahr ich war in
kasachstan in ägypten äthiopien in china
ich habe 1000 euro pro tag verdient ist
es möglich dass ein professor meines
formats der durch die ganze welt fliegt
und so viel geld verdient immer noch
bestechungsgelder von froodies braucht
um sie an politiker weiterzugeben
ich wurde mit 25 jahren in oxford
aufgenommen ich hätte in der ganzen welt
jeden job haben können
war berater vieler gesundheitsminister
[Musik]
privat hatte er geld zur verfügung
die turner
kreativität thiemel nehmen wir mal an
seine aktivitäten waren legal
das unternehmen gab im projekte deren
budgets überhöht waren
daher erhielt er sehr viel geld
war es egal ob er irgendwelche minister
bestochen hat oder nicht
korrekt durchs ministerium
das ziel wurde erreicht und das war
genug für novartis
ich bin ein mensch der nie geld für sich
genommen hat nichts die politik hat mich
nur geld gekostet ich war immer loyal
zum einem mit dem volk zu dienen und ich
bin stolz auf meine karriere als
minister
georg jahres wird in die geschichte der
griechischen politik eingehen als der
minister der seinerzeit das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen zerstört hat er hat in
eine einzige nacht zweieinhalb tausend
ärzte entlassen
es gibt viele beweise dafür und ich sage
nur eines zum harvard project
cdp da guckst du die militärisch sie
können sehen dass alle diese medikamente
ab august aufgrund eines minister
beschlusses auf den griechischen markt
kamen und
das zu einem sehr hohen preis denn
dunkle zu warten
was auch zu preiserhöhungen in anderen
ländern führte
war die internen entscheidungen von
novartis wurden von georg jahres
umgesetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe bereits im parlament erklärt
dass diese anschuldigungen unwahr sind
und dass nichts davon jemals passiert
ist was glauben sie denn dass ich
bestechungsgelder von novartis
angenommen und dann an die troika
weitergegeben habe ich verstehe die
anschuldigungen nicht ich war minister
und wollte armen patienten zugang zu
innovativen lebensrettenden medikamenten
verschaffen ich bin ein seriöser mensch
diese ganze geschichte um novartis ist
in meinen augen ein großer witz
[Musik]
und doch gibt es ein dokument in dem der
direktor von novartis constantinus
france es dem damaligen minister georg
ja das sagt welche maßnahmen ergreifen
soll um das gesundheitswesen zu
reformieren
lua bikini an wir sprechen ihn auf dem
parteitag seiner partei an
nicht einmal gesprochen am herzen
die reformatorischen oder diese
informanten sind lügner wenn wir an die
macht kommen werden wir ihnen jeglichen
schutz entziehen und herausfinden wer
sie dazu gebracht hat all diese
verleumdungen auszusprechen und zwar nur
um politische unruhen in griechenland
anzuzetteln
wurden sie von professor man ja duckies
beeinflusst damit sie sich zum wohle von
novartis äußern
ja das war mein assistent sehr
vertrauenswürdig er war auch der kontakt
zur troika wenn hermann jadakiss korrupt
war würde das bedeuten dass alle
europäischen institutionen korrupt waren
er hat gute arbeit geleistet er war gut
in dem was er tat und er hat mir sehr
geholfen ich danke ihm von ganzem herzen
und ich denke er gehört zu den menschen
die zu unrecht beschuldigt wurden
in einer der e mails geben sie ihm
anweisungen sagen ihm was er tun soll
kamen all diese e-mails von novartis von
herrn fußes
moment ich habe sie dabei voll am 11 ich
weiß von welchen e mails sie sprechen
wenn sie die e mails sehen und wissen
warum ich froh sich gebeten hat sollten
sie erkennen dass wir die dinge anders
gemacht haben die informanten sagen dass
sie die erlaubnis zur herstellung von
zehn sehr teuren medikamenten gegeben
haben
ich habe die produktion von 400 neuen
produkten genehmigt und darauf bin ich
stolz und hier geht es nicht um
entscheidungen die das ergebnis von
korruption sind es war eine sehr gute
entscheidung die viele leben gerettet
hat man sollte nicht vergessen dass
unternehmen wie novartis geld an
mediziner und politiker zahlen und auf
diese weise leben retten
[Musik]
die verantwortlichen hören auf unseren
rat weil sie wissen dass wir das beste
für die patienten wollen
wir sind mehr als nur ein partner des
gesundheitssystems wir sind mehr als
andere unternehmen oder verbände
wir sitzen mit ihnen an einem tisch weil
wir für innovative unternehmen wie
novartis etwas bewirken wollen
deshalb sagen wir verkaufen vermarkten
und den markt gewinnen die
[Musik]
conquistadores koalitionen überhöhte
verschreibungen einschüchterungen
korruptions pläne bestechungsgelder in
millionenhöhe
aber was hat nur wartest zu diesen
anschuldigungen zu sagen das unternehmen
weigerte sich erst den in den skandal
verwickelten direktoren zu erlauben
interview zu werden und gibt stattdessen
lediglich eine erklärung ab
sechs positionen media ticker so christo
in grätsche die medienberichterstattung
über diesen fall in griechenland hat
viele sensationslust seine äußerungen im
zusammenhang mit einer komplexen und
hochgradig politisierten debatte zu tage
gefördert in die novartis und ihre
mitarbeiter nicht verwickelt werden
sollten
[Musik]
wir halten diese politisierung für
völlig abwegig und werden unsere
mitarbeiter und unser unternehmen vor
jeglichen übergriffen und unbegründeten
anschuldigungen schützen
sollten diese rechtmäßig sein werden so
schnell wie möglich alle vorkehrungen
getroffen um eine wiederholung zu
verhindern alpine die premiere des iwi
situation analoge
[Musik]
wir haben verschiedene flüge heute um
mitternacht
wir müssen sehr vorsichtig sein
vorsichtig mit allem
wir haben angst vor allem und wir wollen
diese angst auf diejenigen übertragen
die für alles verantwortlich sind
im moment sind wir diejenigen die angst
haben
sammeln sie immer noch beweise
jahrtausende denn wir wollen alles
beweisen
heißt das dass eine oder mehrere von
ihnen noch bei der warte sind
ich kann nicht mehr sagen
ich kann sagen dass wir im kopf dieser
menschen sind
wir wissen wie sie denken
wir haben das gesamte system aufgedeckt
diejenigen die an dieser entwicklung
beteiligt waren
wie sie alles gemacht haben wie sie
alles kontrolliert haben
wie sie die spitzenpositionen erreicht
haben wir haben das herausgefunden wir
sagen nicht nur oh wir kennen die ärzte
die das geld angenommen haben
wir haben die strategie aufgedeckt
petra stehen sie
tagein tagaus denken sie nur daran wie
sie noch mehr geld verdienen können
genug ist genug
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie er lustig lang
pharm
das sprengt
[Musik]
apa
wir sind
[Musik]
nein